ability is interested in chance right
the charm its probability upset events
happen in a preventive you know an event
like tossing heads or rolling two sixes
in a row or something like that okay so
probability is a fraction we've got a
probability of zero that means it's
never gonna happen it was a probability
of one that's like 100 percent so it's
definitely going to happen and
everything else is in between right so
it's a fraction what are the new Brandon
Dominator for the fraction of its
interval what guys on it's hot yeah the
word they use is favorable as in we want
this to happen right so for instance how
many ways are there to say roll two
sixes right well when you've got two
dice there's only one way to roll two
sixes right favor without events that's
or outcomes on the top and down the
bottom you've got total I really should
say actually I think this is you've got
total outcomes here that's a came back
to the dice if you roll two dice there
are 36 possible outcomes right so in
that case it would be 1 or 36 and this
total outcomes down here it has an
important name right
it's called verb that's where this
sample space yes
okay
now understanding probability to do it
well has two components to it and they
correspond to the two parts of this
fraction right number one you've got to
know all the ways that you can get the
right outcome and number two you need to
be able to count properly there's total
outcomes right and sometimes you need to
adjust that and what we call conditional
probability so conditional probability
is where you know some kind of condition
like I know that I've rolled an odd
number right so that's a condition and
that affects your total number of
outcomes it restricts it in a certain
way it's like a restricted domain okay
right now the two tools that these to
adopt wheats refer to are really about
understanding the sample space at the
old identify the favorable outcomes out
of them so let's do a diagram to show
you what it looks like let's draw up a
table let's make it let's see seven by
seven seven by seven squared
cells
all right so a look at the dice
situation that we had before so it's
called a dot diagram because all of
these events that are actually gonna
happen sometimes represented with dots
I'll draw them in a second but depending
on the kind of question you get
sometimes it's not useful to have dots
at all so what does this represent each
of the dimensions of this table
represents some event that's going to
take place right and the fact that I've
got two dimensions me this is going to
be two minutes occur simultaneously so
for instance with the dice right you
might call all the across the top you
might call this your first die singular
right and your second dive across the
left-hand side so you've got a whole
bunch of outcomes one two three four
five six for each one okay now from here
if you didn't get taught anything else
you would just put dots into these spots
here and that's how you can count all
right if I if I filled them all that I
have 36 total outcomes right and that'll
be my sample space okay sometimes the
question will be a little more specific
for instance it says you roll the dice
and you take the product of the two
numbers that are on the upside faces
right so therefore what you put in here
instead of dots is take the products
right because they're going to be useful
for you when you're trying to work out
one of the favorable outcomes so let's
fill it in as if the question was about
four products right
okay great now of this you can read off
some simple things for instance if we
asked what's the probability of rolling
two numbers and the product being a
square so if you have some other colors
there they might help you because this
diagram is going to get very confusing
very fast right which ones are the
favorable outcomes well mark them in
some way
for instance if you've got another color
you put an X to the side one that's a
square number 9 16 25 36 okay so what
are the advantages of having everything
laid out in this kind of a table format
is that depending on what they ask of
you sometimes it's very orderly right
you can see it's obvious obviously in
diamonds right so this would be and
don't skip this step the favorite
outcomes in this six of them right
divided by the turnaround becomes 36
okay so now I can simplify this and I
get my final answer so try to avoid
going straight there I mean if it's a
one more question then fine but even so
even if it's just one mark write this
down so if you get this wrong you come
back in your checking later you'll know
that ah it's because this number was
wrong with this number was wrong rather
then it's just the air type and you have
to start from scratch all right let's do
another quick example suppose I think I
said before we apply a condition like I
know that the first day is an odd number
I know that the first thousand moments
so what's the probability of getting a
square product if I know that condition
again just like over here trying to take
a shortcut in writing the probabilities
of these things into your questions it's
very common that you'll get given a
scenario and then you get asked three or
four different probabilities right so
rather than all of them being P equals
this p equals our P equals that I
shouldn't show me how they different
okay so now we apply our conditions
right now another color look what you
want to do is eliminate all of the
options that I now invalid right so I
know that one of the dark
dice dice dice hasn't had number okay
Friz is the first one that means it
couldn't positively be 2 or 4 or 6 now
because I've knocked out those
possibilities right that also knocks out
the entire column that goes underneath
them okay so now two things have changed
number one how many square products are
left well there's only three left one
two three right so that probability will
change but also the total number of
outcomes has changed right so I knocked
out half of those as well so there's 18
so in fact we're this condition it's
easier to count to you you apply a
condition but the probability is
actually the same because you're
reducing both the number of favorable
outcomes and the number okay and
obviously there's all kinds of
variations on this but you get the idea
but you want to adjust your diagram
okay well look at our trade irons in a
second and these weird addition and
product rules maybe if you like those
before you probably have used under the
names so give me a second all of this
off and then we'll move on to the
seconds